write a love letter from a burning
building
how important are prompts in a writer's
box of tools
I think they're really important I I'm a
big believer in writing from prompts I
one nice story about prompts when I was
the student is I had a teacher who gave
me a prompt which was
um write something from the point of
view of an unreliable narrator and I
ended up developing my answer to that
prompt into a story and it ended up
being my very first published story so
prompts can lead to stories that are
fully realized works that you know that
come yeah that come from prom so that's
one thing that I I like about them
um but in terms of giving my students
prompts which I I do every week
um
I I like to give open-ended prompts in
which the
students can explore and discover all
kinds of different things from doing
them I usually give them a word limit so
it's usually 750 words per class
first of all what I want them to do is
be generating new work all the time I
mean if you want to be a writer you have
to write I mean it's it's different than
like thinking about writing and planning
writing and and plotting writing but
really you want to be writing
if not every day as often as you can so
prompts get the students generating new
work
also I really like prompts because they
often lead to surprises because the
writer is using an outside suggestion
and so the writer has to sort of invent
and answer or an invent a story that is
something he or she might never have
thought about and it also lends itself
to taking risks and I think
learning how to take risks as a fiction
writer is really important like not to
just do things the way you've always
done them but to do things that might be
difficult you know let's say that
there's a town that you've always wanted
to write something about but you've been
afraid for various reasons to write
about that town like you might use an
exercise which you don't have to worry
if it'll ever see the light of day it's
just for your own personal use you can
write something about that town or write
something about a town that's like that
or you know there are all kinds of
subjects that might be difficult to
write about but you can approach them
maybe in a way that works for you when
using a prompt another thing I like to
encourage students to do when they're
working with prompts is try to write as
much as you can without stopping to edit
as you go along sometimes writers have
an easier time if they do it by hand it
they stop less you know with word
processing it's so easy to stop delete
cut and paste you know
you can really slow yourself down that
way so if if it's possible to get used
to writing without stopping as much I
encourage that
um and then you know I like to explore
different elements of fiction writing so
you know write something from the point
of view of an unreliable narrator that's
a great example of that like that's a
certain kind of Storytelling
um
so
uh and I guess the the other thing I
would want to say is that I have a
subscription service on my website where
everybody who subscribes it's like ten
dollars a month uh I send one original
prompt
um by email every Friday and I get a lot
of really nice response from these and
people who take these prompts and and
really develop them
um I thought I would just
give you one example of
a prompt that I use regularly this is a
prompt that I
often or certainly sometimes use on the
first day of classes as an in-class
exercise and what I'm really among the
many things I'm trying to do with this
exercise
I'm trying to
have the writers think about fiction as
an improvisational activity rather than
an overly planned or over determined
activity you know sometimes
you know Apprentice fiction writers
think I have to know everything I'm
going to say or I can't begin to write
and I would say that I I understand
where that thinking comes from but you
might want to sort of enlarge your ways
of thinking about writing and you know
just start writing like just start
writing a story so my opening sentence
exercise goes like this I say okay
take 10 minutes
and write five opening sentences
don't overthink it don't plan it don't
think about what the sentences mean or
where they're going just write five
opening sentences that you think would
be interesting and I don't say anything
more than that because I don't want to
sort of prejudice them in any way about
where this might be going
okay so once they've all written five
opening sentences I will say something
like this
now choose one of them and revise the
sentence
so that it reveals something significant
about one of the characters including
some problem that the character is going
to have to deal with Okay so
the fact that they have five choices is
important to me because I want them to
know
they could have gone in five four other
directions like a story
takes flight
through the writing of sentences and if
if if that if that writing of sentences
you know
gets you to be able to
start a story then just follow that and
if it turns out that that one sentence
is not very inspiring to you just ignore
it but I just want students to remember
they have lots of options like stories
can go lots of different ways and there
are lots of good ways to tell them
so
now they're going to revise one of the
sentences so that it says something
significant I want them thinking right
away about significance about things
that matter
I don't just want banal details right
um and then I want them thinking also in
terms of okay how can I start thinking
about some kind of problem that the
character has to deal with obviously not
every story starts that way but many
stories stories do start that way
um some some problem that the character
is going to have to deal with and then
finally I say once you're reasonably
happy with that one sentence try adding
a few more sentences that help show the
problem and develop the situation it's a
very open-ended prompt like I'm not
telling them at all what to write I'm
giving some suggestion of how they can
open into a new story and then sort of
take it from there and
I also like to get students thinking
about open-endedness rather than over
determination and what I mean by over
determination is
if the student is like absolutely sure
of what the last sentence is going to be
it's really going to
change the way they approach every other
sentence because they're thinking oh
it's got to end this way
but if you don't if you're not thinking
about How It Ends if you're only
thinking about how it's getting going
then you'll realize actually there could
be many good ways that this story could
end it could go in a number of
interesting and compelling directions
anyway this is a prompt that I really
like
so five prompts and then you want me to
choose one right and why am I choosing
that one is it calling to me exactly
it's calling to me okay interesting and
so then from there then I'm flushing out
that sort of beginning line and then
then I go into this story and the 750
words well
um that that wouldn't be for this one
this is like an in-class exercise
usually if like
Iowa I think in 1973 and
you know students there weren't used to
writing from prompts and he came in on
the first day I believe and gave them a
prompt and I think some of the students
sort of
resisted it and others went along with
it and I don't think he gave a word
limit
but his prompt and this is sort of the
kind of prompt that I like uh write a
love letter from a burning building
and you've got 750 words and so like and
and your the building's going to burn
after X amount of time so you've got to
like it's urgent you have to get right
to it now
um like that's a prompt that if I get I
have given that prompt and I would give
it 750 words and so it creates urgency
not only because the building is burning
but because you have to say what you
want to say right away you don't have
like a thousand pages
how do prompts make a writer better
huh I think um I think really through
the ways that I suggested in terms of
learning learning to see fiction writing
as an improvisational art art that
every sentence is really an
improvisation on the previous sentence
that you might have some sense of where
you think the story might be going but
your sense is not absolute it's subject
to change and if you can sort of
keep you know your basic through line
but also the story can take turns and
you are comfortable with it as a writer
you can write really interesting stories
that way I mean hopefully it will help
Apprentice writers be more flexible in
their thinking like this is why I'm not
a fan of external structures like I want
students to like see that there are a
lot of ways to structure a story and
like you want to discover the one that
is really going to work best with
the story that you want to tell
um and so some of that is being made up
as you go along and then there's also
you know what Flannery O'Connor talked
about the habit of Art and the habit of
being where
like learning to be a fiction writer is
learning to see the world as a fiction
writer sees the world and learning to
sort of
you know perceive things and use them in
ways that you would do in in writing
fiction and the only way to do that is
to practice and practice and practice I
mean you just
that's part of why writing every day is
important is you're you're just using
that I hate to use a cliche like using
that muscle but that's what you're
that's what you're doing you're you're
practicing an art every day and